thank you uh any apologies for absence
yes councelor Steve Pickering chair yeah
thank you minutes of the last meeting I
show you Mr Declarations of Interest
Declarations of Interest any
Declarations of
interest on
screen s Martin can you confirm that the
meeting has now
started about
thank you
Martin is there any Declarations of
Interest no thank you minutes of the
last meeting
then in front of
us happy to to
move all in
favor thank you medium-term financial
plan Revis budgets are you going to yes
this is a revision of the 2324 budget
that was approved by the council last
January revisions will be approved by
the council as part of the budget
monitoring process with the medium-term
financial plan in January you will
recall the incredibly High inflationary
pressures that had to be absorbed into
the general budget last January and as a
result the shortfall 748 th000 was
funded from resilience
reserves although the revised budget
review the call on reserves has now
reduced from
425 to by 425,000 to
331,000 and I do expect that we will
identify further serving savings during
the remainder of the year to reduce the
call on reserve
further table one in the report shows
the main variances the key ones to know
note are the higher than budgeted pay
settlements and the increase in pension
costs will also note the increase costs
of temporary accommodation a trend which
is mirrored nationally and lower forus
and low than forecast planning fees
increased income has been generated in
Leisure Services and there's been a
reduction in utility costs which have
begun to fall from last year's high
level there are no major changes to the
income and the HRA budgets
however there has been a need to
increase the management fee P to Regal
Homes who have been experiencing similar
external pressures to their budgets as
ourselves and have also been managing
financial burden of R of the rigorous
demands on the impending social housing
regulations the capital program has
detailed in appendix 4 which includes
rollovers from last year's uh
approved by the council in
July I would like to move the
recommendations in one one a one b and
one C
chair I'll Che
that any questions on the budget thank
you any you want to s j no thank you I'm
happy thank you are we all happy with
those
recommendations yeah thank you that's
great uh the next one is the council
plan objectives and update April to
September uh that that I've got uh as we
said uh it's uh we we've got the new
council plan uh that that we've all got
the things for uh and there's uh within
that there's uh obviously
four
uh what segments would you call them a
great place that cares for the
environment a great place to work a
great place to live well and a great
place to access good public services and
we are uh developing I think so word
lead a new way to to monitor that to
monitor progress on those uh and we've
come with these I believe you've took
most of these to scrutiny committees uh
the last week or so except communities I
think that
canell uh how did that go really did it
did it go well
Le on
screened no no worries uh feedback from
scrutiny was largely positive um some
particularly like getting the additional
information they like the fact there's a
lot more scope and breath it was a they
were able to generate more of a
discussion around some of the things
that are in there and then ask questions
as well so um so I think it's a positive
start we're at the beginning of that
Journey obviously but I think it gives
them more scope and it it will help them
with their reviews because it's just it
can feed into some of the work that
they're doing so largely positive so it
was a very interactive sessions with
scrutiny
members thanks G I was just looking at
at 2.2 in the report where it says there
a new way of report reporting progress
against the council plan and it will
evolve over time this approach is wider
and more comprehensive seeking
contributions from all departments and
across the performance
framework it is a new way sort of doing
it which uh uh I think it will evolve I
think there is quite a lot of words in
some of this uh and it's trying
to uh own in on on the the the most
important bit but I like it and like I
say it does relate to what we've set up
and and it it uh it's trying to dtail it
all together going forward pleas yeah
just just that chair if I can't what C
just said I was at one of those
scrutin one recently where this has been
yeah presented and I think the thing
that the stand out for me and and I
think the members will appre J is that
there's a direct link from that those
words yeah right right the way back like
you've just said to the council plan and
and in essence if you're going to
measure our performance then surely it's
against the business plan at Council for
that for year term
so you you were right in what you said
it is evolving and and like the report
says this is evolving and we did say
that at the scrutiny meetings as well
but there's a period of refinement that
we going through and that'll become even
clearer in terms of how that link so I
think
overall if you if you were going to make
an assessment of how effective this is
surely if you've got a performance
management system and framework that
accurately and easily directs you
straight back to what you said in the
beginning terms of what you're going to
try and do and measures against that I
don't think you can ask for much more so
I think it's definitely going in right
direction that's great thank Kathy you
want to say anything else I know it is a
good report and
uh I'm I'm more than happy with that so
I'd like to move the recommendation that
uh that we note the progress against the
uh council plan and the objectives we
noted okay are we all in favor of that
the
second I'll second it thank you thank
you that's
great uh the next one uh planning policy
annual monitoring reports uh this is
Steve got Steve's name on it but uh so
David are you yeah I'm happy surpr some
sh that's fine um so the report
essentially summarizes the the planning
policy position um it it actually covers
the last uh Financial year so this
report covers uh April 22 to March 23 um
and effectively one of the
recommendations is to authorize
publication we're we're uh required by
um statute basically to um um publish
this this annual mon report all councils
that under the same obligation the
actual report itself the actual
monitoring report is obviously very
detailed document um I think in terms of
some of the
highlights um it splits between the
authority monitoring report the
Brownfield land register and then
there's also uh the infrastructure
funding statement so I'm I'm not going
to go through them all in great detail
but I think to highlight some of the the
key things that considered in the cover
report overall the the council's
monitoring framework which obviously um
seeks to measure each of the local plan
policies and how they're performing
overall the judgment is that we're
performing well um there are some areas
of weakness um and one of them that is
highlighted is um the lack of employment
land take up on strategic sites um but
as the report makes clear we're only
part with through the um the local plan
period which is um started in 2014 runs
runs for 20 years um so essentially it's
something to monitor uh the key thing at
2.4 in the report and this is something
that we've talked about the cabinet
before is five your housing land Supply
um and we know the position in relation
to that where it's like to to fall off
trory this is one of the key areas that
the local plan working group looking at
and in terms of reviewing our evidence
base that's obviously a key element so I
wasn't really going to highlight
anything else CH like I say it's a very
long report the um infrastructure
funding statement goes into essentially
where we're spending section 106 uh
monies um I'm happy to answer any
questions on it but in terms of the
recommendation it's basically to to note
the contents and authorized publication
on the council website thank you I'm
just giving direct 120 pages actually in
the publicy or whereever it is itself
yeah Helen and the team are busy there
is a lot of real good information in
there like you say will that be on the I
think on the website it yes so it up and
then I realize
many yeah I mean it is really detailed
and essentially it's the the monitoring
of the local plan you're producing local
plan the local plan working group or
they've already seen yes they've seen s
of this document um and clearly it's all
it's all really about our evidence base
um and the areas that we need to be
working on and constantly monitoring
essentially yeah to work gone into that
i' say yeah Helen and Tim have done a
good job there yeah you should have D
credit for that
David but yeah that's fine then so Al
the recommendation is to not that uh
annual monitor I'll second that chair
are we happy to note that yeah thank you
good work very good so that'll be on the
information in that yes that'll be on
the website over the next few days CH
yeah that's
great uh the next one is this is even
better South oosa combined Authority
statement of Common Ground yeah um yeah
so a shorter shorter report um but this
is really about um the duty to cooperate
which all uh councils are required to
demonstrate as part of the fanming
process um and a key way of
demonstrating that is through statements
of common ground on strategic planning
issues so clearly here we've got the
South yra Region combined Authority
State the common ground and Northeast
darbishire like most of the darbishire
authorities we're a non-constituent
member of the combined
Authority um so again just to pick out
some of the issues in the report um it
covers most strategic planning matters
listed at section
2.2 um I think a couple of things to
pick out in relation to energy and
climate change uh the draft statement uh
commits councils to working towards
cabon neutrality by
2050 um and just to emphasize that
that's entirely aligns with the climate
change strategy that we as a district
council have um in terms of how housing
um that's set out at 2.5 basically says
that Council should be looking to plan
for housing need within their own area
um and a commitment to ensure that
basically plans across the region um
have regard to the the Regional Housing
requirement within that but it's a it's
clearly a local plan for uh our district
is for us to
determine um our housing market area
includes balls over Chesterfield and
Basset law so in terms of our own local
plan evidence base we'll primarily be
working within that housing market area
but this is effectively about setting um
a
strategic document in which we agree to
certain principles but they are very
much high level principles it's not
about the detail of what a Northeast
Aral Lo plan would look like um but it
is an important document as I say in
that process of demonstrating that we
have had regard to wider issues
obviously a lot of planning issues don't
stop at boundaries um so really within
that vein the recommendation is to um
well note the contents and then we would
also be a signatory to this document so
to approve the signing of it by
portfolio thank you chair thank you yeah
again there's there's a lot in
there and again all these things we all
have to sign up to this don't we yeah so
all of the and signature to it that
we're all yeah the um so the S combin
Authority themselves are effectively
coordinating it yeah the objective is
that all of the constituent and
non-constituent members sign it um I
think there had been some question marks
posed by uh Highway Works affecting the
peak National Park but worden's been
revised to I obviously that's a bit
peripheral to us but wen's been revised
to make sure hopefully that they do sign
it
um like I say the weakness for us if we
don't sign a document like this is that
we struggle to demonstrate you know that
we have cooperated at that strategic
level so that hence the recommendation
but I would stress this is not about
setting direction for our local plan
policies and you know in terms of
environment employment land housing land
say you know each area plans for its own
need well that's a pretty basic concept
um so yeah yeah thank you thank you do
you say anything you know with the
authority and the DAR Nottingham share
fairely did will this evolve or will
this stay because I'm just looking at
list there Barnsley and B quite a lot of
Don
this this this will remain because this
is this is this is trying not to take
account of boundaries politically this
is is more about other housing market
area yeah so if you're looking at it and
didn't involve any boundaries or
politics you'd say right they go there's
millionaires that's going up there we
need to we need to be mindful of that
because overall in terms of our area
what's the right thing to do so this
will this remains unless David's got any
other is this remains
irrespective it' be quite common for us
to enter into more than one step in a
common ground so we'll probably in East
Midlands yeah there's nothing really sou
you know when you look at that list
where not not in this one no this one is
this one has been uh organized by South
yor combined Authority so it's very much
focused on that but in terms of those
strategic matters you know particularly
the north of the district there there's
obviously pressures in terms of you know
Sheffield's economy that do impact on on
us uh in terms of you know communting
patterns how in need demand Etc so it's
just in recognition of that there will
be other things but as I say It's Not
Unusual to have more than one statement
of common ground and they will all be
quite high level like this absolutely
thank you and like I say if I'm happy to
sign it or Steve or sign it for yeah on
our behalf so I think the recommendation
is to Endo the content yeah and to
authorize the portfolio to sign it are
we only pay with that
yeah thank you thank you again well
done
that and uh where we urgent
items uh I've got no urgent
items so now we move to the exclusion of
the public and I'll move that the public
be excluded from the meeting during the
discussion of the following items of
business to avoid the disclosure to them
of exempt information is defined in part
one of schedule 12a to the Local
Government Act
1972 as amended by the local government
access to information variance order
2006 the category of exempt information
is stated after each
item all right yeah members content with
that okay Marson um could you confirm
that the stream has now
ended